[Music]
we've seen a lot of great fan art of
Disney Princesses but artists Daria
Artemisia from Kiev has taken all your
favorite princesses and turn them into
modern Millennials stay tuned for all of
our favorite pieces can't get enough of
all things Disney be sure to click that
subscribe button now let's check out
this awesome princess fan art Daria
Artem IVA is one talented illustrator we
love all the ways she's reimagined
Disney Princesses you can follow her on
instagram at daria art arts we have
picked some of our favorite millennial
princess drawings from her collection
Belle Belle from Beauty and the Beast
might be the most iconic Disney princess
of all time Gaston you are positively
primeval she's always a favorite in the
fan art world to Daria has drawn a few
versions of Belle and she always
captures bells essence perfectly so what
would Belle look like as a modern day
millennial woman we loved this first
piece because she takes Belle's iconic
white and blue outfit and modernizes it
in the original Belle where is a blue
dress over a white chemise but in this
one val is wearing cute denim overall
shorts and we are here for it
we just love that overalls are making a
comeback and they look amazing on Belle
take a look at that embroidery
it's the beasts rose with the word love
on the side that detail is amazing Belle
was wearing these overalls over a plain
white t-shirt with rolled sleeves and
she's sipping a coke in a glass bottle
because it just tastes better that way
what would though wear to the beach
though Daria has that covered she turned
Belle's classic yellow ball gown into a
trendy bikini she looks so cute she even
included the tiny Rose details it's
perfection
Ariel Disney's The Little Mermaid gave
us one of the most loveable princesses
ever we loved Ariel's bright red hair
and fiery personality and she totally
just went after what she wanted she'd
make the perfect Millennial woman don't
you think well Daria thought so we can't
get enough of her drawing of Ariel it's
not easy to turn a mermaid into a
believable modern chick but she totally
did it
Ariel's green tail was turned into
high-waisted colored jeans it looks so
great she even made the top of the jeans
look sort of like fins
these aren't your mama's high jeans
these are trendy AF with lots of warm
patches we would definitely buy these
pants and let's talk about that top the
artist turned Ariel's seashell bra into
a crop top of course the white top is
screen-printed with a mermaid pattern it
absolutely works because mermaids are
super in right now it's believable as a
real shirt pattern
Ariel's red hair is kept in its classic
style because she might have the best
hair of all the princesses it really
helps the drawing feel authentic but one
of the best parts of the whole look
might be that tattoo of flounder the
fish so cute like a true millennial
Ariel is sporting a Starbucks cup and
she's sat in front of the ocean of
course Cinderella Cinderella is a
classic Disney Princess she's got a
wicked stepmother and basically works as
a servant after such a tough life
Cinderella deserves to just relax and
enjoy things and that's exactly how
Daria drew her this isn't your regular
Cinderella there's no ball gown or glass
slippers but the artist took inspiration
from Cinderella's iconic blue look
millennial Cinderella is dressed and cut
off blue jean capris she looks all sorts
of comfortable she has paired these
capris with a light blue tank top in the
original Cinderella colors underneath
the tank top she spiced it up with a
blue bra let's she is looking so trendy
and check out that ribbon choker
necklace so cute Cinderella is wearing
sneakers on her feet but if you look
closely they resemble glass this is one
talented illustrator throwing in all
these details what we really love is
Cinderella's background
she's lounging around eating pizza and
she deserves to order in after years of
cooking and cleaning for her wicked
stepmom and stepsisters her bed isn't
made because she just doesn't care about
that stuff anymore and Netflix is on in
the background we love it this artist
also apparently loves coca-cola
as Cinderella has a bottle of that to
enjoy with her Pizza YUM
Snow White the original Disney Princess
may not seem like the type to be a
fierce millennial woman but she totally
is
Daria updated Snow White's classic look
into a perfectly stylish ensemble and
honestly we
totally wear this outfit Snow White's
yellow white and blue dress looks great
all modernized her skirt is yellow and
short we love all the buttons down the
center and it has pockets don't you wish
every skirt had pockets in true
millennial fashion Snow White is wearing
a crop top her white shirt is the
classic ruffled sleeves from the
original and she's wearing a blue tank
with a sweetheart neckline over it who
knew Snow White had such a great style
she is shown here taking a selfie of
course such a millennial thing to do and
take a look at her phone case it's an
Apple which is a nod to the poison apple
from the Evil Queen and can we just talk
about Snow White's trendy apartment
Daria updated Snow White's hairstyle to
make it a little more modern while still
maintaining the original vibe the red
headband is such a great touch to
Jasmine Disney's Aladdin takes place in
a made-up kingdom of ancient Arabia so
you might think it would be hard to
modernize a character like Princess
Jasmine but it's not that difficult for
this talented artist Daria did a great
job updating jasmine we've always loved
Jasmine's relaxed princess outfit it
looks so comfy and what activity is more
millennial than yoga and this fan art we
see Princess Jasmine headed to a yoga
class her blue-green harem pants have
been turned into yoga pants and they are
stylish ones too she even has the mesh
cutouts on the legs her original crop
top made a great workout shirt
we love the matching mesh on the
shoulders a girl has to be able to
breathe and her exercise clothes right
Jasmine's hair is shorter than the
original but it still pulled back in a
stylish ponytail and instead of her
tiara and she is wearing a sweat band
that matches her clothes she's got a
purple and orange yoga mat that reminds
us of a certain magic carpet millennial
jasmine looks right at home among all
the palm trees
namaste girl Pocahontas Pocahontas was
one of the first Disney Princesses to be
more of a go-getter
than a damsel in distress if you kill
him you'll have to kill me too and that
would make her a perfect millennial
woman she's not afraid to stand up for
her beliefs and fight for what is right
we love how Daria has drawn Pocahontas
here this Native American princess is so
trendy she looks like she came straight
from Coachella those high-waisted khaki
shorts are amazing she makes casual look
so good Pocahontas is also sporting a
crop top with a tribal vibe that fringe
is so in plus it came straight out of
the original and we love all the feather
details
she has feathers weaved into her short
black hair there are feathers in all the
colors of the wind
her short bob is a great update to her
hairstyle plus Pocahontas has amazing
tattoos we love those pretty feathers
inked on her collarbones that neckline
is a nice throwback to the original but
it still ties this modern outfit
together perfectly
who knew Pocahontas could be such a
style icon we are digging her vibe
meridah meridah from disney's brave made
waves as the first Disney Princess to
have no love interest Merida had no time
for that business she hated the girly
role her mother tried to force her into
she would rather be out shooting her
beau and exploring it makes sense that a
millennial Merida would be casual AF and
we just loved this drawing by Daria she
is wearing a trendy tracksuit and she
looks super cute and exercise gear daya
caps the same green color from Merida's
original dress but she gave her white
stripes up the side of the jogging pants
she's got plain white sneakers for all
the runnings she gets up to her top says
good vibes only which seems exactly like
something Merida would buy the sleeves
are cut out on the shoulders which is so
stylish and she is a Scottish princess
so Daria made sure to include some plaid
she's got a plaid shirt tied around her
waist check out all of Meredith ink
she's got an arrow and key on her upper
arm and then has a tattoo on her forearm
that says brave with another arrow of
course this is just so Merida Anna and
Elsa everyone's favorite Disney sisters
are the ladies from frozen Queen Elsa is
a strong independent woman with some
amazing ice powers Anna is an easily
excited princess who is full of love for
her sister you sacrificed yourself
I love you as two of the most popular
members of Disney royalty Daria just had
to draw them after an ice storm in
arendelle don't you think they deserve a
beach vacation we do and so does the
artist she turns their beautiful dresses
into stylish bikinis Elsa swimsuit is
sparkly and blue of course she even has
the gauzy parts for an added detail and
we are totally digging honest mismatched
bikini the bottom is the same blue and
gold from her dress and the top is a
perfect tribute to her original look
we love the sweetheart neckline of the
swim top and those ruffled sleeves are
so cute seriously can we get these
swimsuits for next season they are so
perfect Tiana Tiana assured in a new
wave of princesses who don't need a man
and even though she found love we think
the star of The Princess and the Frog
totally captures what it means to be a
millennial woman tiana has huge business
dreams of opening her own restaurant
she's a hard worker and maybe a bit of a
workaholic but the girl knows how to
hustle it makes perfect sense to give
her a millennial update and Daria did a
great job Tiana is seen in a comfortable
jogging suit on a lake background maybe
she finally decided to take a day off
she is rocking a high ponytail her
sweatpants and hoodie are a frog like
green of course and we love that she has
an amphibious naveen screen printed on
her sweatshirt Tiana is wearing a crop
top with her sweatpants it's great
because it shows off her rib tattoos
they are lily pad flowers we love this
detail that shows off Tiana's time in
the swamp as a frog she definitely knows
her roots right miss Tiana looks like
somebody you'd see walking down the
streets of a modern-day New Orleans
Aurora Sleeping Beauty is one of the
oldest Disney movies so Princess Aurora
was in serious need of a millennial
makeover and of course this sleeping
princess meets some trendy pajamas Daria
did an amazing job with this
illustration she is wearing two-toned
pink PJ's and they totally remind us of
her Juarez pink ball gown she looks cozy
her pajama top says love to sleep girl
same naps are the best just ask any
millennial she even has a sleep mask
pushed up on her head it
closed eyes on it it's so Sleeping
Beauty Aurora is enjoying breakfast in
bed or maybe it's a brunch
she's a millennial after all she's also
got a mug of coffee to go with her yummy
pancakes Daria has given us some amazing
fan art but this one might have captured
the original essence the best Moana
Disney's most recent princess is pretty
modern even though her story takes place
in ancient Polynesia
but Moana is a strong leader who does
whatever it takes to achieve her dreams
and save her people I may have gone a
little ways past three and we have two
Moana drawings from Daria they are both
perfect for the first one she said Moana
on a beach of course she turns Mona's
tribal dress into a super cute swimsuit
and millennial Moana would totally be a
surfer we love the heart of Sophie be in
this picture that necklace is so pretty
the second picture of Moana has her
enjoying a burger and fries near the
beach she's wearing a cute tribal style
tank top with fringe on the bottom we
love her red and brown jacket - and her
baseball cap says ocean life the heart
of defeating necklace is a lot smaller
in this picture but it is still so
gorgeous
we love this depiction of Moana which of
these millennial princesses was the
fairest of them all let us know in the
comments that's it for the amazing
millennial princesses from artist Daria
arts aviva for more great videos check
out our community page and don't forget
to subscribe
[Music]